david pittman was just 12 years old when
he was sexually abused by a youth
minister at his southern baptist church
in georgia he told no one you know this
is the person that's supposed to
represent god
and they're doing this so i i who am i
going to tell what what am i going to
tell them i'm a 12 year old who's never
been taught any of these things
the abuse continued for three years the
trauma and shame later led him to
addiction i wanted in just as much of it
as i could so i didn't have to think
about what had happened to me
and so for 20 years i'm abusing drugs my
life
spirals out of control with 14 million
members and 47 000 affiliated churches
the sbc is the largest protestant
denomination in the u.s and a powerful
force in conservative politics but
southern baptists are reeling from
revelations of widespread sexual abuse
of children by ministers and church
officials i think the report did rock
people to their core i mean mixture of
indignation grief for decades church
leaders made extensive efforts to cover
it all up last month an independent
third party report documented how the
southern baptist convention's executive
committee dismissed allegations of
sexual abuse ignored survivors and their
stories and focused instead on
protecting the organization's reputation
and sparing individual congregations
from legal liability
the sbc will consider a series of
reforms including a database of proven
and suspected offenders
predators try to remain anonymous i mean
that's what they do they try to stay in
the background we're going to put a
mechanism in place where as best we can
those people are recognized
and
communicated that they can't keep
hurting other folks the sex abuse task
force will also recommend a full apology
for survivors but the apology is only as
good as the action you know one of the
things that has been frustrating is to
survivors has been a lot of talk
without concrete change
pittman is skeptical i don't believe in
institutional change what i hope is that
there's
over time there is a continuum a
continuum of leadership
that is trying to help survivors if that
takes place then it is possible
for some
wholesale and long-term institutional
change a powerful church humbled forced
to confront the betrayal of its children
rob reynolds al jazeera anaheim
california